overnight yet more russian military
vehicles being moved towards ukraine
these ones heading into belarus
while diplomacy goes on so does the
military build up the rhetoric is being
stepped up too a stark warning today
from britain's prime minister to russia
not to attack ukraine
invading ukraine from a from a russian
perspective
is going to be a painful violent and
bloody business
and i think it's very important that
people in russia
understand that this could be a new
chechnya
in brussels european foreign ministers
also repeated warnings of massive
consequences if russia attacks its
neighbor the day after accusing russia
of plotting to install a puppet regime
in ukraine britain's foreign secretary
promised to keep up pressure on moscow
the reason we put that out into the
public domain is we are going to call
out
every instance of russia trying to
influence democracy trying to subvert
ukraine false flag operations and
sabotage
we are now seeing a significant
ratcheting up of rhetoric and
deployments as this crisis deepens we
are considering to further enhance our
presence in the eastern part of the
alliance
this could include the deployment of
additional nato battle groups
with fears of conflict intensifying
britain and america are pulling
diplomatic staff out of ukraine
britain's embassy will remain open but
is down to essential staff only while
diplomatic staff are being pulled out of
the region western military forces are
heading the other way nato is bolstering
forces across eastern europe in case of
any russian aggression the alliance's
response force is on standby with
additional ships and fighter jets also
at the ready france is ready to send
troops to romania to work with nato
forces there the netherlands is sending
two fighter jets to bulgaria to police
its airspace and one ship and land-based
units are now on standby denmark is
sending four fighter jets to lithuania
and stationing a frigate in the baltic
sea and spain is sending its own ships
to join nato naval forces and this is
what russia is deploying tens of
thousands of troops in as many as 70
battalion tactical groups stretched
along the border with ukraine
the kremlin is accusing the west of
stoking up tensions
america is considering sending troops to
the region britain has already sent
anti-tank missiles
but the government's been criticized by
one diplomatic veteran for not doing
enough to support allies stand against
russia there's a feeling that we are not
putting in the work really to
um
to carry our full weight in
international efforts at the moment
we're putting out press releases but
we're not actually
doing the hard work
nerves are being rattled from the black
sea to the baltic where 20 russian naval
ships have put out to sea with both
sides pouring more and more military
forces into the region the dangers of
escalation miscalculation and
inadvertent conflict are mounting
dominic waghorn sky news